[Music]
how do i overcome binge eating as a
minimalist
yeah so
the reason that you binge eat and as a
former binge eater myself i totally
totally get this as i said i was obese
twice in my life morbidly obese you can
check the photo for proof and love
people use things
it's uh
the reason we binge eat is because we're
covering up our problems it is a way to
control our lives when we feel like our
life is out of control we feel like
there's so much chaos around us
that
i need some sort of control it often
manifests in different ways in fact some
psychologists argue that binge eating is
a
form of obsessive compulsive disorder
binge eaters tend to obsess over their
food in more ways than one the other
side of that is anorexia my wife is a
dietitian and nutritionist she worked at
a university for over a decade and the
number one thing she dealt with was
anorexia
especially young women who felt
they needed to complete themselves they
needed to improve themselves they needed
to better themselves by
not eating
it gave them a different kind of control
but it's all the same thing we're all
seeking control and we do a lot of
things to try to control our lives
because we feel like there's so much
chaos
well understanding chaos is the
beautiful half of it
chaos is what creates
well it creates passion it makes things
interesting
right if your life was completely
predictable all the time what would you
call it bored you'd be bored out of your
mind and boredom is not a bad thing
but we have so much
certainty we lose all the variety in our
life and so you're clinging to some sort
of certainty and eating food and
overeating food gives us certainty just
like under eating gives us certainty in
the moment but it doesn't fulfill us it
certainly doesn't nourish us in fact
many of the things we binge eat on are
empty
calories
same is true with materialism the same
is true with our relationships the same
is true with our calendar clutter these
are empty calories we're binging in
every area of our of our life because we
always think more
is better even with anorexia that's a
type of more more fasting more not
eating
more more and more we never stop to
consider less
less doing and more
being
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free